ingenieure und investoren dem tal am
golden gate haben die menschheit in ein
neues zeitalter
katapultiert und sie machen weiter
man kann leicht unterschätzen was da
gerade passiert
so sagte haben sich ihre produkte in
unser leben und unsere hände geschlichen
[Musik]
leitwölfe des silicon valley predigen
den studierenden seit jahrzehnten ihren
unbedingten glauben an technischen
fortschritt
man kann moderne technik von zauberei
nicht mehr als entscheiden
früher wäre man auf dem scheiterhaufen
gelandet für dinge die heute
selbstverständlich
fliegen können wahnsinn
sehen was gerade am anderen ende der
welt geschieht
der ganzen menschheit verbunden sein
im internet so etwas wie ein gemeinsames
gehirn haben zugriff auf jede
information
all das hätte man
damals
ihr seid die magier des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts
lasst euch nicht aufhalten
das war mein boss der gründer auch von
eurer link ein mann der einen haufen
geld auf eine ziemlich tollkühne idee
setzt
der kanadier hand schenk war einer der
ersten ingenieure im team von neuling
einem projekt von elon musk das mit
sonden durch die schädeldecke
gedankenlesen und vernetzen soll mit
anderen gehirnen mit rechnern maschinen
und dem internet die us-behörden haben
klinische tests an menschen genehmigt
für medizinische zwecke erstmal
[Musik]
das ist der operation roboter
mit einer micro feine nadel die sensoren
ins gehirn setzt
mit einer tollen optischen 3d
präsentiert den stolz von eurer linken
wie feine drähte die signale des gehirns
an die maschine füttern
die drähte werden durch die schädeldecke
ins gehirn geführt
so dünn wie ein menschliches haar sie
sind so geschmeidig dass sie sich bei
jedem hauch bewegen
eine revolutionäre entwicklung von eurer
link dieser extrem flexiblen feinen
sonden ins gehirn
man spürt bei masken jeder geste die
absicht das ungeheuerliche möglichst
harmlos darzustellen
es ist schon ein bisschen komplizierter
aber eigentlich nur ein fitness armband
im schädel mit kleinen brötchen
die chips sind klein aber man kann eine
menge davon auf der schädeldecke
unterbringen dann bekommt man ein
ziemlich komplettes bild von dem was im
gehirn vor sich geht
wenn genügend menschen diese implantate
haben können sie sich über einen server
in einer cloud oder so zusammenschließen
oder sich mit dem internet verbinden
alle gleichzeitig
anschein hat das ausgehalten unter elon
musk zu arbeiten der über ingenieur ist
als gnadenlos fordernder chef berüchtigt
was ist sehr smart und nachdenklich so
wirkt auf die meisten diesem persönlich
begegnen er hat aber auch seine macken
ist sehr umstritten selbst in der
technikwelt
hantschel hat neuling kim guten
verlassen für eigene große pläne eine
chip fabrik im weltraum musk bleibt sein
vorbild
er nutzt sein vermögen um probleme zu
lösen die die ganze menschheit betreffen
manche davon sind existenziell
gefährlich
neuling versucht die vormacht der
menschen zu erhalten wenn künstliche
intelligenz menschen ähnliche
fähigkeiten bekommen
ist enorm vorausschauend und erkennt
probleme die gelöst werden müssen
anführer der digitalen revolution
treiben für die nächste phase hoch
riskante unternehmungen voran bis hin zu
künstlicher intelligenz nach ihren
vorstellungen ohne schranken und
strotzend vor selbstbewusstsein
vorgewarnt ausgerechnet ein mann der
sonst furchtlos scheint elon musk
ich kenne mich aus an der vordersten
front der forscher und ich sage ihnen
wir sollten uns alle große sorgen macht
künstliche intelligenz ist eine
existenzielle gefahr für die menschheit
sie macht mir am meisten angst
gehört zu den wenigen dingen die wir
regeln müssen bevor sie da sind danach
ist es zu spät
[Musik]